hi everyone I am M and welcome to this
amazing video on mlops road map by
simply learn if you enjoy watching and
find these videos interesting subscribe
to our Channel as we bring you the best
videos daily also hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
and now let's get started so mlops is
the next evolution of operations it's a
new way of approaching your D day
operations making it much easier to
manage and more efficient for your team
mlops is about streamlining your
organizations processes automating those
processes and ensuring that you're using
the right tools correctly it's about
taking the time to understand your
team's need and making them happen and
before we move on to what mlops say if
you want to become an AI expert and gain
handsome salary packages look at a wide
range of a ml courses by simply learn
that is in collaboration with top
universities across the globe by
enrolling in any of these certification
programs you will gain expertise in
skills like generative AI prompt
engineering J jpd explainable AI machine
learning algorithms supervised and
unsupervised learning model training and
optimization and there much more on the
list with hands-on experience in tools
like chat gbt Dal python open CV and
tensor flow you will catch the eye of
top recruiters so what are you waiting
for hurry up and enroll now a year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
these courses you can find the course
Link in the description box below and
with that in mind over to our training
experts so here we'll start with what is
mlops so mlops that is short form
machine learning operations is a set of
practice tools and principles that aim
to streamline and enhance the deployment
management and monitoring of machine
learning models in production
environments it draws inspiration from
Dev helps that is development and
operations practices and applies them
specifically to the challenges of
deploying and maintaining ml models
effectively and now we'll see who is an
mlops engineer mlops and devops are both
set of practices that aim to improve the
development and deployment of software
and machine learning models respectively
both practices aim to enhance efficiency
collaboration and reliability in the
respective domain
and now you'll see mlops Engineers are
the people who build maintain and
optimize machine learning Solutions
mlops Engineers have a wide range of
skills including knowledge of data
science software engineering and domain
expertise in the industry in which they
work and now we'll see the mlops
engineer skills so mlops Engineers are
the bridge between machine learning and
operations they ensure the machine
learning models are being deployed and
updated correctly not causing any
problems the technical skills you need
to be an mlops engineer are data science
statistical modeling python or R
programming machine learning SQL or
Linux or Unix shell scripting they also
need to interpret the results of their
models which means they need to be able
to read data on a fundamental level and
understand how it relates to the problem
being solved by the model so ml needs to
have the following plus skills they
should have experience working in an
agile environment be a problem solver
and quick learner understand the
importance of continuous learning and
personal development and they should
also be able to demonstrate knowledge of
at least one programming language that
would be preferably python or Java and
now we'll move to the job responsibility
of mlops engineer so deploying and
operationalizing mlops with a keen focus
on tuning model hyperparameters for
optimization assessing and elucidating
model performance and
interpretability streamlining automated
retraining and model training processes
managing workflows for model onboarding
operations and decommissioning
implementing Version Control and
governance measures for models and many
others so these are the job
responsibility for mlops engineer now
moving to mlops genor salary so in the
ever evolving landscape of technology
and its impact on the job market one
career path stands out with remarkable
potential for growth that is mlops
engineering according to the Bureau of
Labor Statistics by 2024 there will be a
21% increase in jobs for mlops engineers
Which is higher than average for all
careers in this field and now we'll see
the salary of mlops engineer in the US
if you're looking to make a career
change or want to make more money amalo
engineering might be the right choice
top companies like Dell Boeing and
Nvidia and many more are hiring mlops
engineers in the US and according to
glasto the national average salary for
an mlops engineer is
$110,000 annually in us and now we will
see the salary in India the demand for
amalo engineer in India has caught the
attention of major industry players with
renowned companies such as bch IBM
Nvidia and others actively seeking to
add these professionals to their teams
and according to glast store the
national average salary for an amops
engineer is 15 lakhs perom in India and
in conclusion embracing melops isn't
just a choice it's a strategic decision
that can reshape your organization
approaches machine learning and with
that we have come to the end of this
video if you have any doubt
regarding any topic CED in this video
please ask in the comment section below
and our team of experts will reach out
to you as soon as possible till then
stay safe and keep learning with simply
learn staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here